when I sat down with the fine folks from
gaslamp games recently to see clockwork
empires for the first time I wasn't sure
what to expect but a merpeople attack
had never crossed my mind as even a
remote possibility this city management
simulation finds an intriguing middle
ground between the city building of
SimCity and the emergent anxieties of
dwarf fortress now I know to expect the
unexpected in clockwork empires a
management sim that mixes eldritch
Horrors and quaint colonial pioneers
into the same melting pot I also know to
expect a drunk and high populace using
alcohol and opium might make your
villagers happy but it will also make
them lose specific memories memories are
important because they help determine
your villagers needs wants and
personalities gaslamp wants to keep
clockwork empires interface as clean as
possible and has shied away from graphs
and charts the developer wants you to
get to know your citizens as individuals
which sounds interesting but does that
mean clicking on a bunch of people to
find out what all of the people want not
necessarily you can build a bureaucrats
office and hire a clerk who will give
you status reports but let's talk about
the merpeople there's something strange
going on out in the Victorian era
wilderness you could provoke the fish
people that live in the sea by
overfishing and they'll attack you
should that happen you could reduce the
impact on the fish people's home by
fishing less or just set up some turrets
to keep your colony safe or maybe you
find some strange artifact if you keep
it the ground near the character may
become corrupted and poisonous growths
will begin to grow you destroy it that
character may now be obsessed with
researching the source of its power to
try to reclaim their lost glory you
never know what might happen is you
construct your colony your citizens
might even resort to eating each other
if you don't give them access to proper
food but don't worry those fish people
will also leave behind raw fish steaks
when they die just don't be surprised if
they're finned friends make a play for
vengeance
you